[Musique]
anwar est cette semaine retrouvez un
programme de courts métrages monsieur
chat et les chats mise
accessible dès 2 ans parfait pour une
première séance au cinéma que vous
pouvez trouver dans le cas de notre
saison jeune public
cette année on a décidé dans le cadre de
cette saison de proposer un abonnement
pour les familles donc la possibilité de
s'abonner et d'avoir des places de
cinéma et de théâtre à un prix défiant
toute concurrence et donc cette semaine
monsieur chat et les chats mise c'est un
programme de six courts métrages qui est
original parce qu'il mélange les
matières donc il ya un chat un vrai chat
incrusté dans un bain des films
d'animation avec des tissus de la laine
des boutons et donc ses six histoires
autour du quotidien voilà dans
lesquelles les chemises jouer à
cache-cache rangent leurs chambres
prennent le bain donc c'est vraiment
très adapté pour les plus petits pour
pourquoi pas une première séance à voir
un noir et cette semaine les talons de
15 et 10 et 15 dans la salle de bain
[Musique]
beaucoup